eu só tenho muito mais um vídeo e hoje
eu vou mostrar como é que o tempo de
criar um brinquedo como este aqui a
primeira coisa que eu fiz foi comprar um
rolamento e eu estou mais ou menos 50 do
que é bastante caro em comparação com
isto que custa cinco euros em maio mas
isso é porque usa um momento grande e
depois eu percebi que o nome que está
aqui no maio é bem pequenino tem só um
centro do pi entro eu comprei um
rolamento com dois centímetros 2022 de
500 estão comprovadamente mais quem vai
ficar mais barato e pode também comprar
o flamento online fica ainda mais uma
vez tem que tirar essa proteção à volta
utiliza um x ato e depois tem que tirar
o óleo está numas das bolinhas por isso
podem usar água raz mas fizerem isso
usem proteção adequada do ar é muito
importante vocês saberem quando o
diâmetro da vossa pátria em tamanho do
rolamento para sermos tão fácil de um de
vocês podem arranjar um pouquinho no
começo e que seria usar o google
sketchup foi o primeiro problema 3 em
que eu aprendi e é bastante intuitivo
então acho que a melhor coisa que vocês
podem fazer é começar com esse problema
e também é gratuito então super bacana
poder imprimir o objeto e suportei no
formato e ciel importei por um programa
olímpico
ross que é um programa gratuito que
vocês conseguem baixar também na
internet é que o computador vai fazer os
cálculos para dividir a peça por
queimadas
depois quando os carros estiverem foi
que só quer ganhar em imprimir
[Música]
e eu penso já está feito ficou muito bem
eu acho que usa a irmã cuidado e pressão
baixa ou seja fins camadas grossas
porque também não assim muitos detalhes
para ensinar isso eu queria imprimir
rapidamente ea única coisa que eu não
consegui colocar a primeira foi o
rolamento lá no meio tive que gastar
ligeiramento usando lixa e um lábios
a iniciativa um pouco dificuldade em
encaixar uma na outra mas foi bastante
simples de resolver só tive que gastar
ligeiramente este pepino e agora já em
caixa vem e fica na empresa e não sai
com facilidade
[Música]
e aqui está o resultado não ficou nada
de especial em termos de votação isso
acontece porque os treinos lamento tira
esta cruel estava aqui dentro pois
voltei porque quando coloquei novo é a
mãe que começou criará 30 que num
anterior e já no dia vai depois tem um
grande problema é que isto é muito leve
as baterias não tem peso quase nenhum e
é muito importante pelo lateral porém
surgirá então eu só pensava em fazer
outro e eu vou tentar fazer uma coisa
diferente que é tentar que os pneus
sendo as duas só quando começar a girar
preciso usar a força sem tipo e quando
começaram a girar vai ver umas tampinhas
que vão pressionar encontrou éder e
desta forma o olé depois vai completar a
bateria e vai seguir nos agora vai
funcionar nos saímos vou experimentar
[Música]
o
e para os auxílios o fim eu espero que
vocês tenham gostado a terceira vai ser
o feijão fazer outro vídeo achou se
estiver algumas realizações
aí vou comprar um momento novo e eu
também posso fazer isto utilizando as
vossas ideias do design ou seja se você
excluir se vocês tiverem uma ideia da de
uma forma interessante pra isto é só uma
mera fotografia para levar no facebook e
eu vou usar isso como referência por um
deus 3d e isso é que também certa vez o
pessoal está aqui até funciona melhor e
este aqui porque estas duas extremidades
ficam aqui postados contra a palma da
mão e assim vocês conseguem mandar com
mais força